Compared to other places, tourism in the UK, like within the shifts.
Just like non-existent, Butlins,
that's all like you go to one city and it's like, okay, here's, here's a C.
And then you go to another city. It's exactly the opposite.
Every Wetherspoons in the UK, like what are you going to do? The C Oh,
let's go to the pub. What were you going to do in Newcastle? Oh,
let's go to the pub. Where are you going to do in Liverpool? Oh,
let's go to the pub. You know, it's, it's, it's our, to be fair.
That's me in Japan.
But I mean,
Japan has a really strong tourism ministry cause people don't want to travel
overseas a lot of the time. Yeah. There's quite a lot of population.
Japan don't actually have passports and they don't have much time for holiday.
Holiday leaves, really bad culture should have much choice.
They do want to stay, just stay here and they travel the country.
So domestic tourism in Japan is really big business.
Each place has their own unique thing.
So you can sort of cross the border and be like, wow,
it's pretty different in the next kind of project.
Yeah. I did notice when I stayed in the real con, but I parked, uh,
and there was tons of cars. Um, I re I stayed two nights. Right.
But when I went that every single car in this car pocket left,
so clearly everyone was only staying one night, which was odd. You stay one day.
I've noticed that they stay one night and then they're like, but I was like, no,
I want multiple days of this. You're kidding me.
And that's probably because like a lot of them, you know,
with the whole world work culture thing, they just, one day more than two days.
His off is like a luxury. Right. I read a statistic.
The most people in Japan only take half their holiday leave at 20 days.
They only take 10 crazy. Why is that?
Do you reckon that's a shame because your boss, your boss will be like,
you've abandoned the team. How dare you? You know, it's pretty,
what then was a teacher? Like, it was, it was pretty, can be quite stressful.
Taking holiday leave even more ridiculous.
One time I took like three days off and they're like, okay,
I have to get it signed by a supervisor. And then the headmaster,
the headmaster's mum they'll have to sign it. And then I decided, actually,
I don't need that holiday. I'll just stay. And they got really angry. He's like,
what do you want to stay? Now? Don't do this again. You don't have to do that.
And like, they really angry.
I didn't really know why you come back.
And you have work work. Like it was like, your job is like, I don't know why.
Maybe it's because they had to get teachers to look at like do my job for me.
And they had to do sort of things, but I dunno,
but like taking holiday in Japan is not fun.
And you're lucky you worked for trash tastes as a result.
Well, we don't want to, for trash tastes trash, trash,
the system.
Make a t-shirt. We are trash trash. I'm wearing the trash T's t-shirt.
I can remember working in the UK. I mean,
you've you feel pressured to take all your holiday. They like, kind of like,
if you have any holiday leave days left over, then that's like, well,
you can take that out. It's just free time off.
Why are you not taking it right here? It's like the complete opposite.
And I'm not sure if it's the same in other Asian countries.
I feel like it would be less of a pressure that is in Japan because
work culture in Japan is.
It's just seen as let, letting down your team.
And if you do take a holiday leave, you're less likely to, you know,
get that promotion. If you need to work for my company,
you decided to take all your holiday, leave what you can legally be entitled to.
But you don't, I'll be like, come on.
Let's promote gum.
Because Cola off the hook Hydo and ate some cramps. Didn't somebody.
Like a famous, uh, politician got like,
it was like newsworthy that he took maternity leave a man. Yeah.
Like it was new. It was newsworthy that the man took a week off.
He took his meds.
Yeah. The man is entitled.
One week off. And it was, it was literally country news.
And he was allowed to, but again, most people don't in Japan.
Especially for maternity. I think they think that that's the mother's job.
Right? Yeah. That's the thing. I feel Japan in a lot of senses,
like the societal law, like almost exceeds the actual law, you know,
it's like five steps forward in technology. And then their cultures.
It was like 50 steps back. Right? Hold up. Here's a fax machine.
That's why we say to people coming to Japan to work, be careful where you work.
Um, foreign companies operating in Japan,
don't usually have those sort of rules and parameters. So that's always a bonus,
but like be careful where you work.
Cause I know a lot of people that work in jobs, they don't get any free time.
They're expected to go out and drink a lot after work.
There's no border between free time and work hard drinking all the time.
Isn't it crazy.
$12. Chris is just like, Oh, another, another night out. Really? Oh,
I guess in Japan. Do you have to like drink to show?
No,
it's kind of it's your boss will like open up and talk to you about things that
they wouldn't normally do when they're sober in the office. Right. Even as a,
you know, working in a school, my teachers that I worked with,
but open up massively after one drink, they won't even be drunk.
It was almost like having alcohol would initiate, being able to be open.
It's like being in that environment, opens them up.
And I had teaching colleagues. Who'd just be like, I hate that colleague.
I hate X, Y, Z. I hate them. And I'd be like, Oh, okay.
Two beers. Maybe we shouldn't have had a drink.
The flood Gates open. It's what a fascinating thing to experience.
I love that two hours in we're finally starting to sound like an actual podcast.
I still sleep blabbering and he still keep laughing intermittently because
seeing Connor die every time you take a sip of soccer, hilarious.
Let's do it together. Come on, drink the whole thing. I've got a lot more.
This is my second Glasscock off. Look at that. This is my second shot.
You been having baby bird sips or that? Yeah.
All right. Cheers. Crushes.
Beautiful drink and beverage. I'm hope I don't throw up to see WEA.
[inaudible] strange.
Oh, he's actually Downing. Okay.
I love the fact that this is going to be more and it's [inaudible] right.
Never shot socket. It's not designed for that sash sash sash.